so because this is our chance to cut
back and have some film a Deadpool I
figured why not tell the story of how he
stole the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos
and what I'm hoping is that at the end
of this you'll have had a little bit of
fun but also walk away appreciating some
of the unique stories from his
publication history
so Deadpool getting the Infinity
Gauntlet actually takes place in the
story deadpool roasts the Marvel
Universe and came out of the death of
Deadpool event following the final
incursion between earth-616 and the
Ultimate Universe going into seeger Wars
to sidetrack for a second while Deadpool
already had a large cult following at
the time due to the writing of Joe Kelly
Jimmy Palmer Audie Frank Thierry
Christopher priest and Victor Gitchell
er in 2012 during wave 1 of Marvel now
the popularity of Deadpool reached
higher levels for several reasons the
first was a co-writer Brian Posehn
already had a massive following in geek
culture due to his work in space ghost
coast to coast Aqua Teen Hunger Force
Tom goes to the mayor super high me as
well as multiple stand-up routines to
this in for those in the geek culture
community who were aware of Posen's work
but on the fringes of the Deadpool
stories with his involvement alongside
Jerry Duggan his respective fan base
dipped their toes in the water of his
foray into comic books to see if his
legacy of comedy which translate
effectively in addition to this comics
that are labelled as number ones usually
sell more copies due to potential fans
seeing it as a way to jump into an
existing character or team without fear
of being lost in the expanse of their
publication history while characters
like Carol Danvers seem to pick up in
the middle of her history and the story
is focusing on her undertaking of the
Captain Marvel mantle regarding Deadpool
Duggan and Posen follow the same pattern
but what a series a story arch in the
first 15 issues after which they
launched the good the bad and the ugly
which focus on his backstory as a result
the Duggan one of Deadpool can largely
be considered self-contained and the
fans could essentially read these
stories on their own without worrying
about the characters history having said
that as a pop culture icon there was
also no denying that Deadpool's rise to
fame was due more to the smaller
contributions made by writers over the
history of his publications which all
came together to form a Doug and run
what I mean here is that where Rob
Liefeld created Deadpool as a copy of
DC's Deathstroke in the 1990s
Joe Kelly made dental a comedic
character that parodied his own stories
the superheroes of Marvel Comics and the
comic-book industry as a whole
capitalizing on this Christopher priest
began having deadpool break the fourth
wall with writers like frank thierry rah
Brody kill Simone and others
adding their own small influences which
contributed to the greater whole and so
recognizing this fact following the
conclusion of the main death of Deadpool
story Marvel had a series of short
stories commissioned which paid homage
to some of his past writers as a final
farewell having said that Deadpool
roasts the Marvel Universe initially
picks up with wade in the midst of a
robbery after having been contacted by
an unnamed client in addition the client
in question has specified that no matter
what happens under no circumstances is
Deadpool to touch the item he's stealing
but because wade does what he wants when
he wants in how he wants wave seizes the
item and makes his way outside from here
we pick up with danos in his famous
helicopter who's revealed to be the
client funding Deadpool stealing of the
Cosmic Cube now to sidetrack for a
second
for those of you who don't know about
the Thanos copter you're missing out on
one of the greatest creations in the
history of Marvel originally appearing
in super Spidey story's number 39 in
1979 this super Spidey line was an
anthology series containing multiple
short stories designed to provide comics
for a younger audience with entry number
39 featuring Thanos stealing the Cosmic
Cube in his Stannis copter well this
story would end with Thanos being
arrested by the police and taken away
the Santos copter lived on in the hearts
and minds of comic book fans everywhere
so it hoped that it would make its
triumphant return one day now with the
goal of Thanos is to acquire the cube as
a way to stop anyone from challenging
his power with the gauntlet
Deadpool reveals that because the cube
allows the wishes of its user to come
true
he had tricked Thanos by stripping him
of his Infinity Gauntlet and replacing
it with a toy model and so with absolute
power over the universe in his
possession
Deadpool does the only thing that makes
sense he holds a one-night-only most of
the Marvel Universe
following this and after creating a
facility to host the roast weight is met
by the arrival of Howard the Duck now
this is actually a pretty cool treat in
that to the best of my knowledge we have
never had an instance when Wade and
Howard have met one another something
that's also funny here is that Deadpool
makes the case that he's never seen a
roast all the way through now to be
honest neither have I and I feel like
I'm not the only one who gets bored the
longer that roasts go on the only
exception I can think was during the
roast of Emmett Smith when Jamie Foxx
absolutely destroyed Doug Williams which
was hilarious but would that bull having
used the Infinity Gauntlet to assemble
Hulk spider-man Thor Nick Fury we also
find that the audience consists of a
lecture at Wolverine Sabretooth blind ow
Mephisto and most all of Marvel's
universe now with storm taking the stage
the first question she asks is why
Hitler's there now for those of you who
were unaware and Jerry Duggan's run and
coming between several story arcs dug in
alongside Posen created a series of
flashback stories focusing on Deadpool
in the past alongside other characters
in this instance Deadpool and Nick
Theory had faced off against Hitler
during World War two in an effort to end
his reign as dictator with a story would
tie into the historical account of
Hitler committing suicide this story
also depicted Hitler being riddled with
bullets leading to the Nazis passing it
off as a suicide in order to save face
what's also funny here is that Deadpool
doesn't appear to understand how a roast
works in the mind of Wade his intention
was to gather the entire Marvel Universe
together for the purpose of roasting
everyone but because the purpose of a
roast is to make fun of a particular
individual in good-nature between cable
4 and the others the Marvel Universe
ends up roasting Deadpool with Thor
unaware of why he's there not for me
one of the funniest moments in the comic
came when the Incredible Hulk took the
stage as he tells us Hulk is the
strongest one there is
except for when it comes to farting in
which case in which case Deadpool makes
the stinkiest farts now to be honest
this is actually a bit of a surprise to
me and that I had always assumed that
Hulk made the stinkiest farts of the
Marvel Universe and if you think the
same thing post a comment and letting me
know but after going through the first
10 minutes of fart jokes Hulk just
inexplicably
smashes the podium stand and bails out
but from here Duggan and Brian Posehn
poke a little fun at the Nick Fury and
Nick Fury jr. situation now again when
Moffett launched the Ultimate Universe
and introduced the alternate version of
Nick Fury he was designed specifically
to look like seminal Jackson now as the
story goes as far as I understand it
Samuel Jackson had not given his
permission for his likeness to be used
and instead of filing a lawsuit
Jackson stated that if Marvel allowed
him to play the character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe then no issues would
come of it as a result because Jackson's
version of Nick Fury grew to be so
popular and the mainstream Marvel
Universe during the story battle scars
Marvel introduced another version named
Marcus Johnson who is written as the
illegitimate son of the original Nick
Fury from the Howling Commandos wall I
became a bit of a running joke for a
while in that a white guy fathered a
child that looked nothing like him
Marcus Johnson largely remained in the
background functioning within the pages
of agents of shield taking on the name
Nick Fury jr. now picking up a Benjamin
Franklin these characters first appeared
at the beginning of Duggan's run with
Deadpool dead presidents centering on a
man named Michael who believed that the
country was taking a turn for the worse
Michael used necromancy as a means to
bring back some of America's greatest
founding fathers including Benjamin
Franklin Abraham Lincoln and Teddy
Roosevelt under the idea that they would
help to restore America's greatness
well the story would go on to see them
being evil and attending to take over
the world the way the story functioning
as a last hurrah Duggan and Posen
brought them back to simply poke fun at
Wade and his hideous appearance in
addition to this we also see Chiclets
now her character debuted in the digital
series that gauntlet sitting on Deadpool
stealing her as Dracula's bride which
actually led into the one-shot comic The
Wedding of Deadpool in issue number 27
finally the last person to make fun of
Deadpool as part of the roast is Emily
Preston originally dying during the dead
presidents story arc at the events
conclusion Michael had placed his
spiritual essence of Preston into the
mind of Deadpool after which it was
transferred to a life model decoy
allowing her to function without anyone
in shield knowing she was a robot where
Duggan's run on Deadpool will continue
to see her go on as a main character and
wage life by helping him to locate his
daughter Illinois in the death of
Deadpool storyline Emily Preston her son
Wade and Eleanor were among those who
died during the collapse of the
multiverse and the final incursion
finally with Deadpool taking the stage
for his final speech
to be honest I loved this part of the
story Molly makes fun of Alpha Flight a
bit in saying that they're a team no one
cares about which makes sense because I
imagine a lot of you watching this don't
know who they are
he goes on a comment that he hasn't seen
this many members of the Marvel Universe
gathered into a single place says he
killed them all during the story
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe a
delightful tale where Deadpool did
actually kill the entire Marvel Universe
however in a more serious turn he also
says that he knows he makes things
awkward sometimes by hitting on women of
the Marvel Universe and he's done a lot
of terrible things in his past but while
he makes his speech to everyone the
audience actually begins to laugh
maniacally with Reed Richards and dr.
doom coming to the realization that
Deadpool is using the Infinity Gauntlet
to force the mall to laugh now where
this initially seems to be dug in and
post and losing their minds and delving
into insanity while reading this story
they actually reveal that this is meant
to prove a point with void breaking the
fourth wall in addressing us directly
he used the Infinity Gauntlet to reveal
the tragic suffering of his life and
that he's been experimented on by the
Weapon X project subjected to torture by
doctor Killebrew losses former
girlfriend Vanessa Carlysle and had his
head ripped off by apocalypse
to this end wade states that after
putting on the Infinity Gauntlet the
entire fourth wall fell away allowing
him to see us reading the comic as he
states his life is just as real as ours
and having to parade around and funny
stories for our amusement has basically
pissed him off and while the other comic
book characters of Marvel don't know
that their life is a ruse or story
Deadpool expected better of us arguing
that while we may like his stories not
everyone does however before he could
continue his rant he's interrupted by
Howard the Duck stating that he was
Deadpool before Deadpool was Deadpool
now for those of you who haven't seen my
video on Howard this is 100% true in his
original stories
Howard was designed to be a parody of
pop culture ideas in the comic book
industry while he did like the silliness
a Deadpool has become known for the fact
remains that everything Deadpool has
done so far Howard at first or the
exception of killing the Marvel Universe
launching a core of his own and kissing
a clone of himself and so as a story
comes to a close
Deadpool essentially resets the entire
situation using the Infinity Gauntlet
and erasing his first encounter with
Thanos appear
Nathaniel's copter Deadpool relinquishes
control of the Infinity Gauntlet arguing
that is more trouble than it's worth
after which Thanos kicks him out and
into the water below with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and let me know how you guys feel
about Deadpool getting the Infinity ala
did you think the Florida story was good
do you think it could have been written
better let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace